Ahora hay más de 8000 ciudades en el mundo con plantas solares.
Hay 300 ciudades que han declarado autonomía energética total.
Una de mis historias favoritas viene de Medellín
que invirtió en una planta hidroeléctrica que abastece a su localidad,
y la ciudad vende el exceso energético a su país.
Y no está sola: hay miles de ciudades como esa.
Tercero: invertir en soluciones integradas y múltiples.
Las ciudades más exitosas son las que invierten en soluciones
que resuelven múltiples problemas a la vez.
Veamos el caso del transporte público integrado.
Cuando se hacen bien --los buses, trenes ligeros, ciclovías,
caminos peatonales y para botes---
pueden reducir dramáticamente las emisiones y la congestión.
Pero pueden hacer aún más: pueden mejorar la salud pública,
pueden reducir la dispersión y hasta incrementar la seguridad.
Un gran ejemplo de esto viene de Seúl.
La población de Seúl se duplicó en los últimos 30 años,
pero la huella ecológica sigue casi igual.
¿Cómo?
Bueno, el 75 % de sus residentes va al trabajo en lo que ha sido descrito
como uno de los mejores sistemas de transporte público.
Y Seúl solía ser un país de autos.
Cuarto: construir densamente, pero sosteniblemente.
La muerte de las ciudades es la expansión.
Las ciudades deben construir resiliente e inclusivamente.
Esto es Dallas-Fort Worth.
Su población también se duplicó en los últimos 30 años.
Como ven se expandió a los límites de la ciudad y suburbios.
Las ciudades deben saber cuándo no construir
para no reproducir la expansión urbana y los barrios pobres.
El problema de Dallas-Fort Worth
es que solo el 5 % de sus residentes va al trabajo en transporte público.
El 95 % usa autos por lo que es una de las ciudades de Norteamérica
donde la gente se demora más en ir y venir del trabajo.
Singapur, en cambio, lo hizo bien.
Construyeron verticalmente y construyeron viviendas asequibles.
Quinto: robar.
Las ciudades más inteligentes roban, hurtan ideas por todos lados.
No tienen tiempo que perder; necesitan la tecnología de mañana hoy.
Y hacen de todo para conseguirla.
Esto es Nueva York,
pero no solo Nueva York roba, también Singapur, Seúl, Medellín.
El renacimiento urbano solo se logrará cuando las ciudades se presten entre sí.
Y finalmente: trabajar en coaliciones globales.
Hay más de 200 coaliciones de ciudades en el mundo hoy.
Hay más coaliciones de ciudades que coaliciones de naciones-estado.
Miren al Parlamento Global de Alcaldes establecido por Ben Barber,
quien guiaba un movimiento de derechos urbanos.
O consideren el C40, una maravillosa red de ciudades
que ha reunido a miles para entregar energía limpia.
O al Foro Económico Mundial
que desarrolla protocolos para ciudades inteligentes.
O la iniciativa '100 Ciudades Resilientes' que lidera el resurgir de la resiliencia.
ICLEI, CGLU, Metrópolis, estos son los movimientos del futuro.
Ellos comprenden que cuando las ciudades trabajan juntas
pueden amplificar su voz,
no solo en el escenario nacional, sino en el global.
Y con la voz viene, potencialmente, un voto
y tal vez hasta un veto.
Cuando las naciones-estado fallan en su soberanía nacional
las ciudades deben liderar.
No pueden esperar y no necesitan pedir permiso.
Pueden ejercer su propia soberanía.
Ellas entienden que lo local y lo global se han unido,
que vivimos en un mundo global-local
y debemos ajustar nuestras políticas según eso.
Al viajar por el mundo y conocer a alcaldes y líderes cívicos
me impresiona la energía, el entusiasmo y la eficacia que traen al trabajo.
Son pragmatistas, resuelven problemas, son paradiplomáticos.
Y en este momento de extraordinaria incertidumbre internacional,
con las instituciones multilaterales paralizadas
y las naciones-estado en retirada,
las ciudades y sus líderes son nuestros nuevos visionarios del siglo XXI.
Se merecen --no, tienen el derecho-- de sentarse a la mesa.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)